hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and today we
are talking about life
maybe we always talk about life in some
sense most people I've had on the
mindscape podcast or living organisms
themselves
no one has yet noticed that any of my
guests have been chatbots or artificial
intelligences
but let's get deep a little bit here
let's ask what is life what do you mean
by life this is the subject of
astrobiology which apparently grew out
of exobiology I really just learned
these vocabulary words I knew about the
vocabulary words but I didn't know about
their relationship
apparently we used to use the word
exobiology but XO means external right
out there so life on other planets or
other stellar systems or whatever so it
excludes life here on earth but
astrobiology despite the word Astro
being there is now taken to mean just
the idea of life both on earth and
outside so what do you mean when you say
life and there's basically two angles
you can take one is you can look at
actual life of course we're stuck with
life here on earth but that's okay it
comes in various forms you can look at
big organisms right mammals or insects
or what-have-you you can look at little
organisms algae and bacteria you can
look at edge cases like viruses you
could look at things that are not living
but are complicated like chemical
reaction networks and you can try to
draw some line and you can try to say
well this is what counts as life this is
what doesn't there's a whole nother way
of thinking about it which is just a
backup to forget about the details of
chemicals and geology and what's going
on here on earth or anywhere else in the
universe and say what do you mean by the
idea of life it's something to do with
complex systems that can keep going
people debate what life actually is
maybe the processing of information is
somehow very important here so today's
guest Sarah
Amari Walker is an expert on both of
these approaches both looking at actual
life looking at the chemistry thinking
about how the molecules fit together to
form the origin of life whether it's on
here or on other
and also the more information theoretic
point of view that tries to ask what
kinds of structures would count as a
living being even if they were made out
of completely different kinds of
chemistry so you'll be unsurprised to
learn given those kind of interests that
Sarah was actually trained as a
physicist before becoming a full-fledged
astrobiologist so we have a wonderful
conversation here words like entropy and
complexity appear but it's a fascinating
topic we're going to be returning to it
on other episodes in the year to come
how do you look for life elsewhere in
the universe in our solar system what do
you mean by life could there be
different forms of life here on earth
could you make life in the laboratory I
think it's a very exciting frontier and
this conversation is a wonderful
introduction to some of the major ideas
remember that we have a website
preposterous universe calm slash podcast
so don't forget you can go to that
website and you can find complete
transcripts for every single episode so
if there's something interesting that
goes on that you hear in the episode you
don't need to read listen to the whole
episode six months from now when you
want to catch the what that thing was
you can go to the website and actually
search for it those transcripts are paid
for by patreon supporters so many thanks
to them and with that I think we're
ready for some life talk so let's go
[Music]
Sarah and Mari Lorca welcome to the
mindscape podcast hi how do I be here
yeah it's great to have you here
especially because I keep having these
people in the podcast who I just think
are intrinsically interesting and then
in the middle of the conversation I
realized they were trained as physicists
at a young age and that includes you
right that's right so what how did you
get from right now you're working on
origin of life and a whole bunch of
other things maybe I want to dive into
the ideas but maybe to calibrate the
audience when you tell them how you got
to point A from point B sure how back in
history do you want me to go well you
weren't undergraduate or maybe that's a
graduate school a starting school yeah
okay so I started graduate school at
Dartmouth College and I wanted to be a
cosmologists at the time our study
particle physics and so actually to
understand that motivation I might have
to go back a little earlier okay so what
happened was I went to Community College
actually for my first two years of
college and I took a physics class and I
became deeply infatuated with physics
great great so it does go back in
history but it's also a great message to
anyone who's listening at a local
college or something like that's right
yeah I think it's important to mention
so it's quite funny so I was 18 a
two-year college and I was walking
around saying I want to be a theoretical
physicist when I grow up and everyone
thought I had two heads but but to me it
was really important and I had some
really supportive mentors there but I
think what really intrigued me about it
what really motivated me to continue at
University and then to go to grad school
was I was very interested in fundamental
descriptions of nature and what reality
was and the fact that mathematics could
describe so much of reality and that
humans were really good at doing that
and so the actually I actually literally
remember the lecture where I got
interested in physics in Community
College it was like the first day and my
physics professor was talking about
magnetic monopoles and the fact that
they don't exist but we predicted them
and we were going out to look for them
and so that idea deeply intrigued me and
so what I thought was I wanted to be
like the people that were predicting
those things and going to look for them
and so I had this idea in minds that I
wanted to do with theoretical physics
and theoretical physics was like
particle physics and cosmology so I went
to undergrad at Florida Tech and I
studied physics there and I
did a lab that did particle physics oh
it was like working on some calibration
of like detectors for the CMS experiment
LHC and then I went to grad school to do
cosmology and particle physics because I
really want to do theory so so what
happened when I got to grad school was I
started working with Marcelo gleiser who
was my PhD advisor and he had spent most
of his career working on early universe
cosmology and I was very excited about
that topic and trying to think about you
know like where does matter come from
and and reheating after inflation and so
I just wanted to work with him but he
was sorry to work on this thing called
astrobiology and I was like what is that
as I explained to me about the origin of
life field and that you know people are
you know that there were these these
problems on origins of life and and so I
started working on a specific problem
related to the origin of life which is
about the origin origin of Homo
chirality so biomolecules in our bodies
come in mirror image form so amino acids
that are made into proteins come in a
left-handed right-handed variety but
proteins are only made a left-hand amino
acids and DNA and RNA are composed of
right-handed sugars even though you
could have left a right-handed sugar
basis so um so I was busy general
concept of left versus right is
chirality chiral yeah so chiral actually
literally means hand and Greek and so so
it's actually really fun to give talks
like for the public and such because you
get I should wave your hands around like
you so yeah so I'm waving my hands now
but obviously podcast audience can't see
that but anyway so so that was a fun
problem to work on because there's this
kind of unknown you know question in the
origin of life about how life became
homo chiral and what happened in the
origin of life to actually break that
symmetry so if you try to do like
prebiotic synthesis which is basically
making compounds without biology and
making biomolecules you'll get roughly
equal mixtures of both the chiral form
so non biological chemistry gives you
both yeah basically and so so I was
studying that problem but as a physicist
with study so physicists got really
excited about certain classes of
problems as you know being a physicist
but me
the audience doesn't know but there's a
particular problem called the Ising
model which we used to model
ferromagnets for example and you can
talk about like a spin up or a spin down
system and britta symmetry breaking
between spin up and spin down you can do
the same thing with left and right
handed and so so I started studying
symmetry breaking processes and
chemistry from the perspective of a
physicist related to origins of life and
so that was kind of a physics segue into
the problem and it was quite interesting
for me because I was working on that
problem but I was thinking about this
deep motivation I had when I first
started getting into physics about like
you know idolizing my heroes in science
like Einstein and you know Fermi and
Dirac and like these people that had
these really deep thoughts about the
structural reality in advanced like
fundamental understanding of how we see
the world and in figure this origin of
life problem and I'm like that's not and
you know like you know I was taught
physics was these certain sets of
problems but as I started work on it
more I realized that we really didn't
understand the origin of life and we
didn't understand the questions and that
maybe there was some deep physics to be
uncovered yeah in life or in the origin
of life that might actually explain it
so so I had this like transition point I
guess maybe three or four years and my
PhD where I started not becoming
resistant to working on origins of life
as a fundamental problem and realize
that actual reason I caught into physics
in the first place was I wanted to
contribute fundamental understanding and
here was like this place that's like
sort of like the Wild West of science
where nobody knows what's going on and
so you can actually be really creative
and that kind of ideas you bring to the
field and there were very few theorists
working on origins of life so I remember
going to conferences as a PhD student
and it would be like you know 100 people
at the conference and they're all
prebiotic chemists and no theorists and
nobody thinking very deeply about this
issue of what life is and how we can try
to build new theory to try to understand
the process of origins of life I think
also for the people who are not experts
out there it's it's crucially important
that origin of life research is not a
mature field in the same way that
particle physics and cosmology and
particle physics and cosmology we have
what are literally called standard
models and they're correct that we've
tested them and we're trying hard to
push beyond them but it's difficult to
even get any experimental clue where as
an origin of life or like there's many
different models
that's right and I like I like that
about that field so so I love particle
physics and I love like all the things
that have been built but it's like
somehow you want to also be actively
contributing to that so yeah so it's
it's fun about the field but it's also
infuriating because you like you know
you're like constantly not sure what the
question to ask is let alone how to
answer that's right both situations have
their downsides cosmology is it's hard
to make true progress understanding
nature because we understand it too much
right and in origin of life we
understand it to little that's right
that's right
so what do you do but then you got a PhD
you or a physicist but then now you're
sort of not in a physics department
right so when I left graduate school I
went to work at Georgia Tech and so part
of my reason for doing that was I got a
position there I'm working in their
Center for chemical evolution and they
have a really a great group of
researchers they're focusing on origins
of life from the chemistry side and so I
thought I didn't know much chemistry
much biochemistry and so if I went there
and did some theoretical modeling that I
would learn a lot about how chemists
think about the problem and how people
from different disciplines think about
the problem and that was incredibly
helpful but I remember also thinking the
whole time so I was doing these like
models for how like we have these sort
of simple models in chemistry for
original life processes right and so the
idea is we want to study chemical
evolution quote-unquote or the evolution
is leading to something lifelike but we
don't know what life is and so I started
becoming increasingly dissatisfied with
the fact that I could do all these
modeling of origin of life without
having any metrics of success and even
any of this sort of ways we think about
origin of life science are really far
from what we would call life so there's
actually this huge gap in the field that
you know we have like prebiotic
chemistry which makes simple compounds
like amino acids or you know like RNA
nucleotides under periodic conditions so
without biology but you can only make
like the simple building blocks you
can't make big molecules and you can't
make anything as complex as a cell
obviously from such a simple condition
or at least we can't yet presumably that
happened at some point in the past
through some evolutionary
process but the way prebiotic chemistry
is now is very focused on building
specific components of biological
systems and so far we can only get very
simple ones under non biological
molecule by molecule by molecule right
so the the standard of proof in that
field right now is you making a molecule
that's in biology yep
without biology maybe you a standard is
one that reproduces itself right well
eventually but but we're nowhere near
that right so so right now like a
successful prebiotic synthesis
experiment is you make a molecule that's
found in biology without biology and so
so my only point with that is that's
useful right to know what conditions
those molecules can be made under but
it's not life it's nowhere in your life
right and then on the other side of it
like we can trace back phylogenetically
to try to reconstruct what we think the
last Universal common ancestor of life
on Earth is so we have this idea that
life evolved from a population of cells
with um you know modern translation
machinery so like DNA and proteins like
we have today but but when we try to
look back in history we get to like a
certain point where we call the last
Universal common ancestor and we can't
go back any farther because before the
origin will translate can't reconstruct
what happened because we reconstruct
what happened based on DNA and if DNA
you know isn't being read out by the
translation machinery to do something
you know that so it's sort of been
equated in my field to like the the CMB
of biology right so it's like the
surface of last scattering that you
can't actually push back with our
standard way of looking at biological
organs like you were the only one who
would make that comparison I'm not the
only one there are other physicists that
make that comparison so I think I've
heard that one actually first one
Michael Goldman Feld so I know the
physicists working in astrobiology and
and physics of life stuff but but anyway
so maybe is just because I know that I
used to get confused about this the
difference between the first living
organism and the last Universal common
ancestor is potentially huge potentially
huge in years in complexity and what
does that mean in years and complexity
and maybe scale like a spatial scale
which which we can talk about a little
bit but
but so we don't know when life emerged
we don't know where life emerged I think
there's this idea that life emerged as
like a single cellular entity on early
Earth and then it you know started
reproducing itself and evolved to take
over the planet but there's an
alternative set of ideas that life
emerge from geochemistry and with some
organizing geochemical cycle it might
have actually been a planetary process
from the start and I find those kind of
sets of ideas to be more intriguing but
that's what I mean about scale because
you could think about an individual
organism alive a merging and being alive
or you could think about the emergence
of life as this process that's happening
on a planet and then of individuals the
things we call cells or units in biology
emerge much later and that's so so so
just to go back to like where we were
because we can come back to the set of
ideas but I wanted to finish like about
the motivation so when I was at Georgia
Tech I was just like that gap just
really bothered me and the fact that I
feel like a lot of people in origins of
life field although it's been changing
significantly over even my short career
because I think the field is really
starting to move in some some new
directions that are quite exciting for
various reasons that I can talk about
but but just to cut to the the main
point here like that gap was bothering
me in the fact that people weren't
tackling the ordering life transition
directly between making a single
molecule versus traceback yeah versus
having like a complex functional minimal
cell or early living system versus
having molecules that are in that living
system and the steps in between are like
a black box and they still are black box
we don't know what those steps are and
so so then I became deeply interested in
this what is life question how do we
quantify it and then could we build
theory for understanding the transition
from non-life to life what would that
theory look like and how do we actually
quantify this thing that we call life so
that we could actually build better
origin of life experiments and so I
ended up getting a NASA fellowship and
going to ASU after Georgia Tech and
that's when I got back more into like
physics thinking and and that fellowship
my my mentor was Paul Davies and so what
I worked on with him was really trying
to think about the origin of life
transition
more from the perspective of if we think
that there's some interesting
fundamental physics going on there what
is it and what would we say the origin
of life transition is and so I ended up
spending a lot of my postdoc thinking
more like a philosopher I guess yeah
about what I thought the origin of life
was and so by the time I became a
professor what I really I kind of had
this clear idea in mind of what I
thought a concrete way of addressing the
problem was and what I've done with my
research group is basically build
infrastructure to try to build toward
that theory okay and that takes a lot of
forms there's a lot of ways to think
about the problem and a lot of it's
about the role of information in
physical reality because I think that
has a lot to do with what biology is
which I can explain more but but most of
us just trying to understand what life
is so that we can solve the origin of
life so the new year has begun it's a
time to reflect and set goals for the
year ahead and what better goal than
learning something new so I'd like to
suggest the great courses plus as a
wonderful way to learn something that is
not yet quite in your wheelhouse the
great courses plus is a streaming
service that lets you learn from the
great courses these are some of the best
professors that we have teaching a whole
bunch of subjects from science to
history to business subjects one course
I can recommend is physics and our
universe how it all works this is a
broad overview of everything you need to
know to understand the basics of the
physical world whether it's particles
entropy space-time all of the buzzwords
that you've heard about this is a very
user friendly congenial way to get up to
speed so sign up for the great courses
today they're offering mindscape
listeners an amazing deal three months
of unlimited access for just $30 but to
get this limited time offer you sign up
today using the special URL the great
courses plus com / - Cape that's the th
e great courses plus PLU s dot com slash
mindscape yeah definitely in information
theory and its role that's mostly what I
want to talk about but but just to UM so
there's something more concrete in our
listeners heads
what are the theories for number one
what the last Universal common ancestor
is and number two what the first living
organism is is there even a set of
models that people argue about or is it
really just who knows um no there are a
set of and when did they happen I guess
yeah so so the origin of life itself I
think is easier to talk about the
different classes of models because
there are concrete camps so to speak
where people have a particular idea in
mind or a set of hypotheses and they're
actively working on that and so probably
the most famous is the RNA world
hypothesis for the origin of life which
is that life started with RNA as the
primary biomolecule and so the reason we
should even say what are they yeah yeah
so the reason for that yeah is is that
RNA is kind of an intermediary between
DNA and proteins so when DNA gets
translated it's transcribed as
transcribed into RNA and RNA is read out
by the translation machinery into
proteins but RNA also has this dual role
where some RNA molecules fold and they
have function on their own so it can
both act as a genetic molecule and a
functional molecule whereas in modern
biology those roles are mostly split as
DNA being the informational molecule or
genetic molecule and proteins being the
functional molecule that does stuff in
the cell so the idea was if you wanted
to have a simple explanation for the
origins of life and we know RNA plays
both these roles
perhaps RNA was the first major
biological macromolecule now even within
the RNA world though there's a very
varying set of hypotheses about what the
RNA world actually means so you could
say like one extreme end of it is the
RNA world means that a RNA molecule
emerged on the early earth started
copying itself and started evolving and
then somehow evolved into all the rest
of biology and so that really relies
very strongly on evolution being a very
strong force in nature to really
generate novelty and complexity now that
on the other side of it there's kind of
like the softer RNA world view which is
is just the idea that RNA was the first
genetic material and DNA evolved later
so you might have had some
and some cellular structures before you
even had RNA but when you got genetics
it was RNA so replication first versus
metabolism first a little bit so I'll
get to that words I've heard you find it
yeah my lesser knowledge to work here no
no no that's good yeah so so that this
is just just thinking still like sort of
genetics being important so I've I've
actually because I tend to be in the
more in the metabolism camp if I if I
was gonna self-identify as a camp
although tried to be as agnostic as
possible so I kind of wrapped that RNA
is the first genetic material into a
metabolic narrative but but some people
that think that just purely think about
the genetics so they don't make strong
claims about RNA being the very first
living thing but all they care about is
being life is the first genetic things
and then and then there's sort of the
RNA world as part of what are called
genetics first hypotheses and the
genetics first hypotheses doesn't just
include RNA as the first genetic
material but there's a whole variety of
other nucleic acids that could
potentially preceded RNA so there's
things like TNA and PNA and like all
these n a's yeah yeah right yeah and
it's actually interesting cuz people use
these in synthetic biology and show that
like some of these XNA s as they're
called can be functional in modern cells
but there are people that work on trying
to figure out which nucleic acid
polymers can talk to each other
the idea being if you think about
chemistry's hardware that you could have
had a succession of hardware upgrades in
some sense where the genetic information
encoding could have been in one molecule
class and then copied to another and so
DNA copies to RNA which is part of the
central dogma biology that information
flows from DNA to RNA but the question
of that sort of idea of origin life
sciences which polymers can copy
information to each other and it's not
always bi-directional it's like
sometimes you can get information
transfer from one to the next but not
backwards so there's a whole research
industry on that and then alternative to
that is the metabolism first yes right
which is what you were alluding to which
is this idea that life started not with
a molecule that could copy itself and
undergo an evolutionary process and the
sense we would understand is being very
Darwinian where you have a genetic
molecule that copies itself
and has heredity and variation but some
kind of self-organizing set of molecules
which is we call in the field or
autocatalytic set so you have a bunch of
molecules that catalyze a reaction and
then those reactions form a closed cycle
so the system as a whole reproduces
itself and so the idea there is that
there were some auto catalytic chemical
reaction networks of these these
reactions that actually emerged on early
Earth and there's varying sets of ideas
there also so some people think that's
kind of would have been early proteins
would have been the best candidate for
that so you would have gotten you know
some peptides so so polymers of amino
acids amino acids make proteins proteins
are just very big long macromolecules
but if you think short amino acid
sequences that could have catalyzed the
production of other amino acids inkless
sequences you would have gotten an auto
catalytic cycle but other versions of
auto catalytic cycles include things
like a primitive metabolism so there's a
set of ideas that maybe the citric acid
cycle which is a metabolic cycle that
happens in modern biology is actually
the most primitive metabolism and
emerged from geochemical cycles and I
find that set of ideas deeply intriguing
for a number of reasons because it's
trying to tie the origin of life to
planetary processes in geochemistry and
so what you'll notice about sort of and
also I should mention in metabolism
first you know there you get sort of
more emphasis on energy and
thermodynamics and those kind of
approaches and in genetics approaches
it's more like focused on information
and copying and evolution and both of
those things are obviously important to
biology but they've been like sort of
parsed out as separate to be original
life hypothesis and then there's other
things like this you know cell first
hypothesis that you might have just
gotten like lipid vesicles or something
forming an earlier soles yeah and then
yeah molecules would have gotten inside
them and that would have started some
kind of copying and evolutionary process
so there's a whole swath of different
ideas and I think you know what happens
with you each of these hypotheses is
they have
their own set of experiments that are
possible to do but what ends up being
hard about the whole enterprise is that
I think a lot of the ways that we're
thinking about it are a very
anthropocentric they're imposing things
that are biological into chemistry in
ways that maybe aren't there like almost
anticipating the solution and because we
are poisoned by knowing yeah exactly so
so just to think about like that idea I
was talking about before about like when
a prebiotic chemistry that sin life
right like they want to they want to do
origin 'life chemistry well the de blade
you do original life chemistry is to try
to produce something like an amino acid
under non-biological conditions but we
don't know that life started with the
chemistry that it has now there could
have been lots of product like changes
in the chemical structure of what
molecules living systems were using as
they became alive and so I think I think
it gets very hard to say if any of these
things are really in the right space of
ideas well you're doing a good job of
letting the non experts know that it is
kind of a mess because well I mean life
right now it has a lot of things going
on it's not even clear which of these
are most important or could be first and
then do it once okay so it's yeah you
know a wonderful open field to play in
but it can be hard to get a purchase on
something else right and I think and I
think part of the thing is the field has
been really deeply focused on the idea
of the historical origins of life and so
this so what I mean by that is what we
know is that the origin of life happened
once in the universe we think it
happened on planet at least once yeah at
least once thank you for clarifying that
it happened at least once which is what
I meant so we know for sure has happened
once we don't know if it's happened more
than once and we think that was on earth
although you know people have
alternative hypotheses it might have
emerged somewhere else and then travel
to earth but it's easier to assume it
happened on earth and then the
historical originally problem is
concerned with how did life as we know
it arise but you could ask the more
general question about how does life
arise in the universe and then that
doesn't necessarily need to assume the
chemistry's the same and so the way you
frame that question and ask those kind
of questions is actually a little bit
different than the way original life
traditionally has been
posed and that kind of way of asking it
tends to border more with other fields
like artificial life or start thinking
about what life could look like on other
planets and I think that's actually much
more fruitful personally but I think
there's a lot of growth in the field to
really understand how to parse all of
those kind of different ideas about how
to think about it that is very natural
once one has training as a physicist to
try to say well forget about life on
this planet let's just imagine the idea
I know where it could it looks like you
can take the girl out of cosmology but
you can't take the cosmologists out of
the girl it's really just I can't like I
can't get that mindset like but but I
think I think I went into physics
because I had that mindset in the first
place and so so I do think that life is
something that happens in our universe
and there should be some explanatory
framework for what life is and why it
happens and I don't
I personally well I don't know what I
actually think because I try not to have
like a firm opinion on these things
because then it's difficult to make
scientific progress
I think intrinsically I'm hopeful that
life exists multiple places but I don't
know for sure but scientifically I think
the most useful hypothesis is that there
are rules underlying the original life
because that allows us to ask questions
about what those rules might be if life
was such an odd statistical fluke that
we really were the only life in the
universe and then it's not a scientific
question anymore in some senses that
yeah it's like it's just a low
probability how would you actually get
the principles out of it or even if
there were a hundred different times and
life started but they were all different
yes that would kind of be disappointing
to our physicist hard that's really
great but also but actually I think
that's kind of interesting and one of
the reasons that I'm an astrobiologist
rather than say like a biophysicist or a
theoretical biologist is that I think
there is something about the way you ask
about the question of life after
biologically that's actually quite
useful in the sense that if I say I'm
gonna go look for life on other planets
or I think there is this thing called
life in the universe then I really am
saying there's this objective category
that exists that we can call life and it
should have some property common to all
life right and so then the idea is what
are those universal properties the the
challenging thing is those may not be
things that we expect them to be right
so they might not be things like the
molecules are always going to be the
same yeah okay and so that's when the
thing about the idea of information
becomes more important to me because I
don't think that the physical stuff the
molecule
is always going to be the same but what
is going to be the same is that there's
some informational process organizing
matter and that's what life is and what
and then that gets into a whole bunch of
things about what does that actually
mean and and that's where we're stuck in
this kind of like idea development of
how do we actually understand what this
thing is
it does but that sounded right there
like you gave a definition of life I
mean yeah I in my book the big picture I
quoted this definition that was offered
by some NASA panel oh right yes and I
really didn't like it at all it was a
miss life is a self-sustaining capable
chemical system capable of Darwinian
evolution was that the one that was the
one yes so I thought that was just very
blinkered you know and also the fact
that life is capable of Darwinian
evolution in particular is certainly a
historical fact about life but I could
imagine building a synthetic thing that
we would all agree is living but it's
not capable of Darwinian evolution right
missed the point yeah no it says it's
definitely missed the point on a lot of
things and and that's one of them I mean
even across life on earth Darwinian
evolution is not the only mode of
evolution that we know exists so for
example the last Universal common
ancestor I was talking about like
horizontal gene transfer was really
important so it was more of like a
collective evolutionary process because
individual units weren't clearly defined
yeah so back in the day that you would
pass genes back and forth to your
friends not just here yeah exactly
exactly and and and microorganisms still
do that like it's still a really
dominant mechanism of exchanging
information even in modern systems and
then you have things like cultural
evolution which is not necessarily
Darwinian and so we do know that biology
uses a lot of different ways of changing
over time and changing information over
time besides Darwinian and you can
theorize about all kinds of different
ways evolution could work so that's one
of them the Darwinian evolution I think
the part that actually bothers me more
about that definition and also about a
lot of definitions of life as they
assume life is chemical and that
chemistry needs to be in the definition
of life and I think I think there's a
major confusion between chemistry which
is the scale of physical reality talking
like a physicist where life emerges and
what life is so I think chemistry is the
scale where information becomes
important
is a part of physics I don't think it
really matters at smaller scales in
physical systems and I can talk about
sort of what I'm what I mean by
information and chemistry in just a
minute but but I think life is like I I
think when I think about what life is I
think about you and me being life we're
not just chemistry technological
civilizations are life multicellular
organisms are life so I think life
emerges in chemistry but it's this
process of information organizing matter
as I was saying but it happens across
many scales at that are you know and and
part of what's interesting about life is
life is actually like this
hierarchically organized process so we
we talked about this idea in
evolutionary biology of major
transitions in evolution the first one
was the origin of life but subsequent
ones are you know origin of
multicellularity an origin of social
systems and all of that structure is
still part of life but we don't
necessarily talk about chemistry there
and so so I think I think that's
actually really important I think part
of it is also this idea that you know
when we're talking about defining life
we need to talk about an individual cell
this is also something that's really
kind of interesting to me because we
really fixate on this idea of like the
definition of life should describe an
individual and so one of my colleagues
Michael Walkman at Santa Fe Institute is
really interesting the way he thinks
about it because he the way he thinks
about a cell is a cell as a current
manifestation of an evolutionary lineage
but you can't really separate the cell
from the fact that it has this long
evolutionary history so he would talk
about the unit of life actually being
the lineage and I think that's a really
nice idea but I also think when you're
when you start thinking about expanding
your definition of life that way that
you can't really just isolate the
lineage but you need to think about all
the lineages and so it's almost like we
had an Origin a life event and when we
talk about life it's the origin of life
event and all the subsequent structure
that emerge from that and it's it's like
this information structure that's
constantly constructing all of you know
these individuals and in all of these
processes by having information
distributed in space and time and it's a
that's actually what life is and the
natural boundary for that actually ends
up being the planetary
scale and so I think a lot about the
biosphere as being as a whole as a
proper unit of life and then when we
study the components of the biosphere is
it's like partitioned into things we
call individuals or societies or
ecosystems and those are all part of
that living structure but you have to
consider the whole thing
right right okay that's a very different
perspective than people usually take it
is and so you're expanding the scope of
the thing both in space and in time
right so there's basically one life life
is so hard the origin of that process
right yeah yeah and so so I think I
think very much about this idea that
like you know there's some there's some
scale where this physics becomes
important and then what is that scale
and that was kind of part of once once
you get the process of life going it is
this kind of expansion process in space
and time and we're building more
structures like tables and microphones
and things by informing information
accumulated or evolutionary history but
getting that process started is quite
interesting and so one of the points I
was making about chemistry and why I
think this physics emerges in chemistry
and maybe not at lower scales so the
origin life is is always maybe going to
be happening in chemistry is that when
you think about chemical space like the
possible set of all possible molecules
it's infinitely huge I mean it's it's
like it's uncountably huge people they
every you know if you look at the
largest pharmaceutical databases we have
they have millions of compounds and it's
not even scratching the surface of the
size of the number of compounds you
could make even with just a few elements
and it's just combinatorial just comic
or especially carbon molecules yeah yeah
it's a huge combinatorial space and so
so Stewart Kaufman has this idea he
talks about a little belt like the
adjacent possible but like once you get
into molecular space it's like you have
so many structures even for a protein of
possible molecules that not everyone
could possibly exist within the lifetime
or resources of the universe yeah and so
so what happens in chemistry that at a
certain scale is that not everything
that could exist will ever exist and so
to see something like a protein requires
a lot of information to reproduce it in
the universe reliably because there's no
otherwise it would just be a statistical
improbable fluke and this
with a table right and so I think the
process that we need to understand is
how does how does information emerge or
what is information and then how does it
make it so that things like cups and
tables and very complex molecules are
reproduced in the universe reliably well
clearly the idea of information is
playing a huge role thinking about this
you've already mentioned it so I know
that's maybe let's focus in on this a
little bit I mean I'm asking a lot here
but is there a simple definition of what
you mean by information these other
things great so so I should say that
there's there's obviously something
called information theory which people
talk about quite a lot and was developed
by Claude Shannon in the 1940s and you
know it's a huge industry of people that
work on information theory and I use
information theory a lot my work but
that's not exactly what I mean but when
I'm talking about information relevant
to physics of life and so information
theory will often talk about you know if
you have a quantity of information it's
somehow related to your reduction in
uncertainty about a process so so if you
walk into the room carrying an umbrella
you know my uncertainty is maybe reduced
about whether it's raining or not
outside because you had an umbrella and
you were bringing it to work today so so
there's some information in the umbrella
that I can have about predicting what
else is happening and so that's kind of
what people usually think about when
they think about information and Shannon
was interested literally in sending
signals over while yeah right so yeah so
it's very much about communication and
there's a lot of caveats there about how
which might get more into like the
technical details but like it also
requires that you have some way of
encoding the message right so it
automatically assumes a lot of things
about what a physical system is to be
able to communicate because it has to
have a semantic representation or some
kind of symbolic way of describing
things that both the sender and receiver
understand so that the message can be
decoded and so that's already a very
large set of assumptions and I think
whatever physics underlies information
like that should be kind of a property
that drops out of the physics not
something you impose on it and
is it safe to compare this to my
favorite example like if I have a
textbook that is written in French yeah
don't speak French in some sense it
doesn't convey any information exactly
yeah yeah that's exactly right and so
yes and so so that's kind of you know
the way people usually talk about
information is within that sort of
formal formalization what I'm interested
in is the fact that there seemed to be
some processes that require some kind of
abstraction or some kind of
representation that can that's not
necessarily tied to the physical
substrate so like an electron has
charged right and you can't remove the
charge from the electron right the like
that is a property of the electron but
information is quite different in the
sense that like you know I'm holding a
lot of young is that how you pronounce
this and I never know Evian water bottle
right so I can read F yang and now like
I you know I have that word in my mind
right but it's it's existing on the
water bottle which is one kind of
physical material my mind is a different
kind of physical material and then I'm
talking about it into this giant
microphone which is really quite large
but and you know now it's it's traveling
over you know wires and is now on
somebody's computer that they're well in
the future will be but my now and
they're now and different and and you
know it so it's information that can
exist in a lot of different media right
but somehow it still has the same
property that it means the same thing
and all of those different instances and
that's a really intriguing property for
something physical to have and so this
gets into like a lot of deep
philosophical debates about how physical
information actually is because it seems
to be this abstract quantity or property
that can exist in many different media
can be copied between media and it
doesn't have the same physical you know
that like something like electric charge
has although it's a little bit like
energy because we think about energy
flowing by change yeah so energy is
actually quite an abstract concept also
but we have more concrete theory for
understanding energy as a physical thing
and I think information we don't and my
favorite example to use about why I
think information is really different in
the kind of physics that it me
is to actually think about examples of
technology because they're very visceral
so chemistry is hard because chemistry
seems very abstract it happens inside
ourselves we can't experience it in our
daily experience but I like to use this
example of like launching satellites
into space and to think about that as a
physical process and so if you think
about what's necessary for like a planet
like the earth to have thousands of
satellites orbiting it which we do all
there most of them are artificial right
we have one natural satellite and then
we have all these artificial satellites
the artificial satellites are quite
interesting because in order for them to
be there requires that you have a
technological civilization or some kind
of intelligent process with knowledge of
the laws of gravitation and engineering
principles to actually build little
metal boxes and throw them into space
and it's that idea that knowledge of
regular information about regularities
of the physical world and the ability to
control them to mediate new physical
transformations like launching
satellites into space that really
intrigues me about information because
in order to get to that point you had
this long evolutionary history we had
biological systems learning about
physical reality or learning about their
environment the way biologists would
talk about it and they'd gradually
acquired all this information to the
point that you had science emerge on the
planet and then learning about
gravitation and formalizing it in
mathematical laws and those mathematical
laws are information and they allow us
to do these transformations in the
physical world that wouldn't be possible
without that information and so we are
David Grinspoon has this nice way of
phrasing it that we're a planet that's
anti accreting matter matter we're
flinging matter into space so people you
know planetary formation they talk about
planets accreting to form so they're
they're creating matter and they're
they're forming planets and then you
might get a few satellites and then you
have this weird kind of planet that has
life on it and it's evolving over a long
time doing all this weird stuff and then
suddenly it's anti accreting and I think
I think that's a really nice example the
fact that that process just wouldn't
happen without certain kinds of
information in the system and I really
like this David quote that David Deutsch
has in one of his books which I use
almost all the time in my talks because
I love it so much but it's um it's
something like base metals can be
transmuted to gold by the powers that
the processes that power stars and by
intelligent being
understand those processes and by
nothing else in the universe so there is
something about intelligence as a
physical process that's quite different
because it's like physics happens and
then you have biological or intelligent
systems that understand physics and then
they they can make these transformations
that are not physically impossible like
it's not impossible to launch a
satellite just into space it's just if
you just had physics and chemistry and
no biology you know organisms no
evolutionary history acquiring
information you would never see a planet
launching satellites into space so it
sounds like you haven't quite given a
formal definition but it sounds like
what matters to you about information is
somehow a matter of potential or ability
or leverage you can somehow affect the
world in a way because yeah right so so
it's sort of about like the
possibilities that are like I use the
word causation a lot which people have
various problems with and I have
problems with a little bit myself
because it's it's kind of a loaded word
but but what's interesting to me is what
can happen causally in the universe and
I think there's a lot of processes that
can happen but just don't and that what
biology does is it somehow can cause
things to happen that wouldn't happen
outside of the kind of process that
biology is and you could call that thing
that's causative information but somehow
it's but and you and so I think there's
a deep connection actually between
information and causation back to
philosophy and then we're back to
philosophy and there's a huge you know
industry and complex systems trying to
understand that deep connection and I
don't think anybody really you know I
think a lot of people have a lot of
insights into it but we don't really
understand it so so I guess I mean I
think life is information structuring
matter what is information in some sense
it's like causes that can be copied
between physical systems okay
and so there is kind of like a framework
there but but you know it's it's really
funny because every once in a while I
have with my research group that's like
we just like to pounce on them at group
meeting I'm like let's have a what his
life discussion today and everybody has
to write on the board like their
definition of life and it's amazing how
much it changes you know but but that's
good I think it's productive because it
wouldn't have been in a particle physics
meeting what is the electron yeah
exactly
yeah yeah so I think I think a lot of
our challenges you know we have a really
loose conceptual cloud of like what the
right space is but how to actually
penetrate it and build a rigorous theory
and have the experiments to test against
everything this is just really hard it
sounds like this goes well beyond the
question of origin of life or the nature
of life because as you mentioned there
is something called information theory
you can buy gas book it's called
information but in some sense you're
hinting that we are lacking a full
theory of how information interacts in
the world or what information does and
can we can quantify it yes right there's
entropy information correlations but the
interface of maybe information and
energy or information at work or
something like that yeah
yeah no I think that's that's very
accurate so I do think that there is
like a missing physics and some sounds
like you know various people like to
describe different ways for me I think
there's you know like there have been
major revolutions in physics and if
we're gonna have the next major one like
quantum mechanics or general relativity
was it would be somehow physics of
information but that's my bias obviously
go out there yeah we got it we got it we
gotta go for it right so um but anyway
so I do think I do think it's like it's
a fundamental property of our universe
and it's pretty ubiquitous so it exists
outside of life right and it should tie
into other ways we think about physics
and exist in other physical systems but
I think what's interesting is like I
make an analogy sometimes of thinking
about gravity like it's like gravity
exists everywhere or like at least you
know like space-time exists everywhere
but sometimes like if we want to study
you know gravitation gravity like you
know at its most extreme and we really
want to get insights into like curvature
space-time and things we study things
like black holes if you want to
understand information and how it
operates in the physical world I think
you study something like a living system
go to the limits yeah because we're we
are literally like the things that exist
where that physics is most evident right
okay so does that kind of perspective I
guess I have two questions one does do
other people share this perspective the
other one is are there tangible ways in
which it might help us understand the
origin of life yeah so um I think other
people do share the perspective it's I'm
not gonna say it's a majority view
obviously and I you know I tend to
want to work on majority views because I
feel like there's more room for other
people doing that yeah exactly and also
part I mean one of my goals actually
thinking about the what is like question
is like I don't know if I'm right or not
right and in some sense one of the ways
I justify like why I pushed so hard on
trying to be to like really push the
boundaries of how we think about that
problem it's just that I think that
needs to be done and whether the way I'm
doing it is the right way or not is
subject to discussion debate and you
know scientific inquiry and invalidation
against experiments once we like can
build the right theory but but it also
hopefully will you know get people to
start just start getting out of our
boxes and think about the problem
differently which I just think is like
desperately needed so I think I think
what I what I do do in my work and
something I think my group is quite good
I work with like an insanely talented
grad students and postdocs but we always
are trying to think about like what are
the experiments and how do we actually
connect to experiments or real datasets
and so my hope is that there will be in
the same way that like physics has
really progressed because of the
interface of theory and experiment like
that's something that really needs to
happen in origins of life and not in the
sense because I make a distinction
between modeling and theory in the sense
that like a model a model is something
I'll describe like a particular system
right so I can build like a mathematical
model that will describe you know a
particular enzyme and how it functions
or something but you know if you have a
theory it's it's much more encompassing
and explanatory and simple
yeah yeah exactly so so I think I think
what I in an theories are more
predictive I think across different
systems and maybe that's just my own
personal classification but I make that
kind of distinction because I think in
origins of life we've had a lot of
modeling it's not like we're absent of
theoreticians but we don't have any
motivating theories really I mean all
those hypotheses are you know like
they're very they're very specific kind
of like model it's not talking about
general principles so I don't I don't
really think of like the RNA world
hypothesis is a general principle for
origins of life it's a very specific
kind of set of idea that was designed to
be experimentally tractable and really
life on Earth but what I would really
like to see the field move toward is
having theory for what we think life is
and trying to test it by doing
experiments that could test it or
looking for or using you know searches
for life on other planets as tests of
hypotheses about what life is you give
us an example of something that you
would either do or advocate people doing
in the lab yeah so so one of the things
I think is so there's been this kind of
like newer set of ideas related to what
was like so-called quote-unquote messy
chemistry and origins of life which is
like messy chemistry so people are doing
a lot of this kind of like like soup
chemistry so it's a little bit like the
miller-urey experiment was done you know
the 1950s and it was like famously
produced amino acids from some [ __ ] but
the idea is now to try to like have you
know some some simple building blocks
but have have them coupled maybe to an
environmental source and also do
multiple experiments so so my ideal
scenario and actually like I do I work
with experimentalist so so one lab I
work with is leaked Cronin's lab at
University Glasgow and they do these
kind of experiments so I've been on some
work with them on that but but they they
take these soup chemistries and they try
to change the environment by like having
different minerals introduced to the
system as a like as a function of the
like changing the history of the
chemistry or changing the pH and there's
a lot of like hydrating and dehydrating
and so you have these environmental
cycles that you introduce to these messy
chemistry's and then what you see is you
get really different product
distributions out of different histories
but what's interesting is you never
reproduce the same exact set of products
but you do reproduce features so in I'm
sorry if you do this same experiment
twice yeah afferent answers
yeah because chemistry stochastic okay
so yeah just random fluctuations right
yeah and and and also I mean it's just
like these are you know lots of
different molecular species and the
combinatoric so we were talking about
before and then molecules can be
catalytically active so they change the
nature of the distribution and that's
exactly the kind of dynamic you want to
get to life right because you want a
changing history over time we kind of
early adopter of exits one molecule
comes into existence early it can change
the whole it can change the whole future
yeah exactly and that's exactly what we
want to look for and amplify and
understand the statistics over and so in
some sense it's like we need a
statistical approach to chemistry in the
same way that people took a statistical
approach to understanding you know like
thermodynamics and the 1800s and things
but like how do you actually do
statistics over chemistry is really
difficult because chemistry is you know
quite what I see with information theory
is coming in yeah exactly yeah and and
so what I like and also it's sort of
like you know physicists are obsessed
with like macro States and micro States
right and I like this because I'm
starting to get into like a macro scale
view of chemistry right you don't care
about the specific details of the
chemistry in the history but maybe
there's some macroscopic properties in
the chemistry that are reproducible
given a certain history and those might
lead to specific features that are
lifelike potentially do you think that
the origin of land this is something you
just have an opinion on I'm not
necessarily something you have
established but do you think that when
life started it required some leap some
sort of very unlikely fluctuation or was
it more or less inevitable given the
condition um I am not sure how I like I
get asked that question a lot and I've
thought about a lot and I don't think I
have a firm opinion one way or the other
I think what I do think is in some sense
like if we think the origin of life is a
reproducible process that if you get the
right conditions it should happen but
with the likelihood it would happen is
still uncertain okay and so so with
these kind of experiments one thing that
I was describing that I like is like
they're they're being roboticized so you
can automate this process and so I have
in my mind this vision of like you know
like a large-scale original life
experiment which people have actually
tried to get off the ground various time
so there's been a lot of talk over many
many years about like when CERN you know
finally shuts down maybe they allocate
all those resources to origin life stuff
and I like it's my secret hope they
don't think that they're planning to
shut down no no but no but I don't think
so either but I do know there have been
several original life meetings at CERN
talking about like whether some of the
resources from certain could be used for
urgent life weather and whether that
will ever actually happen or not as
another thing but I do think I think one
of the things is like right now the
field is as you were saying before like
it's in this very
early stage of development right and
it's it's like we don't have standard
models and we don't and and so it's like
every isolated lab has their pet theory
they're working on and the experiments
you know they're exploring one tiny
regime of chemical parameter space and
one tiny set of conditions and imagine
if we could get all those labs together
and build one massive experiment that
was exploring like the statistics over
what's chemically possible when we start
to get lifelike structures and when we
don't and what what I like about that is
is because we don't know the probability
the origin of life we could at least
start to build experiments to bound it
right so so we have like for example
your is it hard yeah so for example we
have like this super coming akanda
experiment which is trying to bounce the
proton decay right and so every time we
don't observe that event we know it's
less likely right so could you think
about the virginal life that way and it
would be like I'm much more agnostic way
of thinking about the physical process
because you're now looking for things in
chemistry to happen and trying to
characterize them rather than imposing
what you believe is like the origin of
life story probably orders of magnitude
less funding for origin of life research
for particles yes yes yes is that just
because the achievements have been less
tangible so far I think so and I think
there's less convincing narratives okay
to be honest because I think like when
you when you go through all the
different hypotheses people have their
they they tend to be very disciplinary
divided and they tend to be very you
know there's not like a clear passage
lots of investment would be needed to
and this would really solve the problem
and I think the challenge for the origin
of life community is that we really do
need to build that convincing case
because if we are going to solve the
problem I think it's gonna have to be a
massive international scale effort it's
not a trivial problem to solve but we
have in mind our mind that each little
lab is gonna solve its one little part
and then suddenly the whole narratives
gonna come together and like you know I
mean what the miller-urey experiment was
really almost ridiculous the way the
newspapers were talking about it because
I got amino acid in a couple days and
then you know they had these pictures of
like you know aliens crawling out of the
test tube and it's just like it's like
we're excited yeah yeah and I think I
think at the time it was right it was
very revolutionary that that could even
happen at all so then they thought well
maybe the subsequent steps should be as
easy but we haven't found that
case and they might be it might just be
we're looking at the wrong conditions
and maybe somebody's lab will just
magically pop out some new alien
life-form but but I find that highly
unlikely so I think I think there does
need to be sort of a transition in the
field as far as how we frame the
question how we think about the question
how we collaborate to make headway on
the question and I think we're just not
quite there yet
is there any usefulness and either
replacing or augmenting these chemistry
experiments with computer simulations or
is it just the space of possibilities to
long i my personal opinion on that is
gonna be a little bit philosophical but
I think there is something different
between simulated reality and real
reality okay physical reality and I
think if you want to simulate things in
a computer it's fine but I think since
we don't know the physics we actually
have to do the experiments well we know
the standard model of particle physics
we do indeed but I you know I'll be
there no okay I don't think it's enough
okay I think this is where we're gonna
diverge no I know I'm sure we're gonna
diverge on say it say it out loud what
do you really think that the the core
theory the standard model of particle
physics is not up to the task of
explaining life yes I do I don't think
how could it how can we change it well I
just I mean I think it operates at a
certain scale of reality and it's really
good at that scale and I think that
there are probably other kinds of
physics that emerge at other scales like
you know longer length scales longer
timescales and and that's really where
the physics of information or whatever
this thing is that we're talking about
exists and it's somewhere in chemical
space and it's it's just not it's not
encapsulated and what we call I don't
know if you know of course the the word
emergence is something that people
disagree about what it means yeah so we
actually we'd since you brought that up
I'll just mention this is really funny
but like it my group meeting yesterday
we were just talking about all these
words and everyone just wants to throw
away information complexity emergence
and life and some like all these words
are just so loaded it means so much is
missing free will you decide on yeah
yeah yeah well we are talking about
those and like trying to throw them away
in decision-making is another one that's
hard so there's like all these yeah that
we concepts we're struggling with where
people don't know where the words are
there is a nice paper a classic paper by
mark but
about what he calls weak immersions
first strong and other people have
learned about this too and basically his
suggested delineation was properties at
the higher scale are weakly emergent if
in principle you could put the
microscopic theory on a computer and
simulate it yes and get the answer
whereas they're strongly emergent if you
can see them at the higher level but you
could never even simulate the thing if
all you knew where the microscopic yeah
laws and so I'm a big believer in weak
emergence not in strong emergence but
you're a big believer in strong emerges
and part of my reason for that is the
standard model is an equation written
down by humans and it emerged from human
mind and so I have actually so one of
the thoughts so we're all the other
equations yeah I know exactly so I think
I think there's something interesting
because we want to try to reduce biology
to physics but physics is an emergent
property of biology and I think I think
that's actually deeply important and so
one of my favorite sets of thought
experiments that I play around with now
is to think about what math is as a
physical system and so so a lot of
people are interested in mathematical
physics and you know why is it that math
you know like Vigna had this
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics right and so like we don't
understand why math corresponds to
physical reality so well and then you'll
get people that you know like like max
tegmark mathematical university offices
just all math exist somewhere innocent
podcast casters yes okay good there you
go can refer to that podcast so in which
I like it's elegant but I think I think
what's interesting to me to think about
is to think about math as a kind of
information and one that evolved out of
biology and and I think it's a really
interesting microcosm of trying to
understand the physics because I think
the reason that we think that
mathematics does work so well for us as
the language of science or physics is
that it's the kind of information that
is the most copyable between different
physical systems so if I make a semantic
statement you can misinterpret me we've
been debating information you know for
the last however long we've been talking
but if I make a mathematical statement
you know exactly what I mean right and
you could put it in the computer the
computer knows exactly what it means
right so there's sort of a different
quality about transferring information
between physical systems in mathematics
than in semantic language or in any
other kind of way that we may
have abstractions or represent
information and I think that's one of
the reasons that mathematics works so
well describing physical reality is
because it's this abstraction that our
human minds have evolved that's really
good at being represented in different
media and that that's also probably in
some way why we get dualities in physics
while like one kind of physical reality
looks the same mathematically is another
kind of physical reality there's some
kind of bias because we're able to look
at certain things at certain ways yeah
yeah and so so I think I think you can
make those kind of arguments about the
standard model but I'm always intrigued
by this idea that the standard model is
a it's effectively a coarse graining
that we've made of certain regularities
we've seen in the world in this
effective description that works really
well but we're a physical system that
made that model yeah and and we use that
and we made that model to Bill like and
we use that model to build giant
detectors that can probe like the
smallest scales of physical reality
right but like in order to get to that
loop you had to go through a system to
even like be able to construct that and
I think I think that loop is really
deeply intriguing and there are some
physics that describes that loop that's
not encoded in physics as we know it
because we have to suddenly it's in a
it's actually in some ways that's deeply
relators a problem.we observer in
physics right because we don't know how
to put the observer into physics all
this reflection self-awareness recursion
I guess is the word only yeah and I
think that's why it's so hard because we
don't we don't know how to reason about
ourselves diagnostically well what about
I mean you you had this definition of
life maybe you didn't claim it was a
definition this way of looking at life
is something it uses information to
manipulate matter can I ask where the
information comes from and do you have a
picture of the universe starting with a
lot of information and life learning to
take advantage of it or is information
created in the process of life being I
mean existence I think it's it's created
with life in some sense I think the
physics is there but I think biology is
accumulating or generating information
and in some sense like if you wanted to
go to a Shannon desk definition it's
sort of like the exclusion of
possibilities this table exists so it
has a lot of information in it because
if we want to think about all the
possible configurations
could be this table most of them are not
this table okay so to make specifically
this table it requires a lot of
information so if you wanted to go to
like the traditional physicist narrative
you can think about that and that
biology is basically storing the
information specific to a table but the
weight we're generating information yeah
that's what I want to know the
difference between wasn't there and we
organized it or so in your view is
information conserved um
I've debated this a lot and you know fax
me this question all the time is Paul
Davies actually he's like another
physicist I don't know okay I am deeply
intrigued by that question
I am deeply mystified by it so I think I
think one of the questions I keep going
back to there's a lot of things that
kind of like I can't decide which side
of it I'm on and and one of them is is
precisely your question about whether
the origin of life is the origin of
information or if information preceded
life but there's a sense in which both
of those are true yeah different senses
of the word information yeah yeah I
think yeah and I think I think that's
also hard about working in new
conceptual spaces because when I use the
word even I use it in different ways
even yet like so so I think I think like
when you're trying to build a theory you
have many ideas of the theory in mind
and they're conceptually related but
they're not all identical and then like
where you are in the space of ideas and
any given time shifts and I think that's
healthy for developing new ideas but
it's very hard to describe what you know
like you can't say something concrete
about some of it and you could be on
both sides of that seem like they
disagree with each other because why
don't we spin it as saying that you know
to the young people out there listening
who might decide to be future origin of
life information theory researchers
there is a lot of possibilities there
are a lot of possibilities out there
there are there's a lot of scope for
creativity questions that are easy to
ask and hard to answer yes yes I think
it's hard to ask the right question
right and then when you ask the right
question it might be easy to answer so I
would actually flip it you know okay
that's also true that's also true so
easy to ask some questions hard to ask
the right question yes yeah and I think
that's where a lot of the creativity is
is like how do you know which question
ask okay but let's so let me rephrase
the angle I've been getting at
is it something that information that
thinking about information has brought
to the table already that has been very
helpful in understanding how life comes
to be or is it more I think
Esper Asian I think it's an aspiration
but I think some most help there's a
couple helpful things about the dialog
as far as reframing how we think about
the life problem that I find really
useful and I think should be useful to
the community independent whether they
think information is the right way of
think about it
one is that life should be quantifiable
in some way that you know there is like
a property of life and and it's not like
a black or white criteria that the
system is not alive the system is alive
but there might be more like a scale of
life like the system's more alive than
that system because it's more of a
manifestation of that physics in the
same sense you have deeper gravitational
potential Wells or something right so
there should be some kind of you know
objective property it might be a high
dimensional space of objective
properties right because life is a
complex system and so we might just need
to figure out like all the parameters
that we need to measure to say something
about how alive but at least this idea
that that life life has universal
properties and they're ones that could
be formalized in a quantitative way like
but does not interrupt but yeah you sort
of made this point that if we ever went
to another planet and found an
artificial satellite circling yeah we
would not have found life but we would
know there's life down right yeah
exactly
somehow there can be the impact of life
on the universe exactly can be something
that goes hand in hand with life without
right right exactly so I do think that
life has like an indelible imprint on
the universe in the sense that it
actually generates things that would be
impossible without that and well guess
what you're getting at is we would like
to be able to know you know how to
quantify that yeah no let me see it yes
exactly exactly so so that's one another
one is that life is not like like we
have this idea of life being chemical
and we need to define it in terms of
individual units like a cell is a
fundamental unit of life but that it
could be more about like a process that
occurs over space and time and that's
much more of like like there's this
whole field of open-ended evolution that
just wants to understand what kind of
processes can generate structure
indefinitely right okay there's an
open-ended process and so you might
think about life just as that
processed you mean outside of
specifically Darwinian biological yeah
just yeah what is open-ended evolution
does it actually exist in our physical
universe those are interesting questions
to ask because there could be physical
bounds on how much intelligence
technology could do or how much biology
could do because we you know we have
this idea that biology generates novelty
and that's and our technology generates
novelty and there might be physical
bounds on that process and so does it
continue indefinitely and how open-ended
actually is it but but but that's just
to bring in like a separate set of ideas
to the mix but just the idea that life
is not necessarily bounded in the
physical structures we observe and there
could be something like something hidden
underneath that and the same so like
it's interesting to me that people think
like life is going to have this
definition that's obvious based on the
physical structures we see it reminds me
a little bit of like when people are
trying to describe planetary orbits with
eppie cycles right so it's like you have
these like you know these models that
are just very obvious based on like what
you actually see but they're completely
unexplained Ettore or predictive and
then you know it took a long time and a
lot of deep intuition and deep thinking
you know for Einstein eventually till I
come up with this idea of the curvature
of space-time underlying gravity and
that is like deeply unintuitive it's not
like I sit here feeling like I'm
embedded and you know a space-time
manifold and it's curved right now so I
think I think to think that the physics
of life doesn't have something equally
odd and interesting underlying it is is
is something that's really hindered the
creativity of the human mind to really
approach that problem do you think we
could be living in a simulation
potentially but I think I think that
questions kind of I think amiss guys
thinking right so I think I think one of
the things that's interesting for me is
that like we take computation for
granted in the sense that we think like
computation can happen in any physical
system and it's equally equivalent and I
think that there is something about like
some physical systems can do some
computations and some physical systems
can do others so I don't think that
computation is like it the same way I
don't think mathematics is abstract and
exists autonomous to physical reality I
don't think computation is either and so
I think you could ask it for a
simulation but I think simulations have
to be instantiated in the properties of
that physical media actually matters
so the idea of simulating whole
universes I think would still ultimately
have hallmarks of whatever physical
system underlied that okay somewhere yes
maybe I thought that where you're gonna
go is you know and I'm not sure life can
exist in a computer I guess from that
perspective well that's where I was
gonna go because you're talking we're
talking about you know the different
ways of life could could be and whether
I was gonna ask whether we could make it
you know
purely virtually whether that would
count in some sense well so um I don't I
don't think it would count and I say you
could make a projection of life in a
computer but I don't think it would be
quite the same as life in chemistry but
it would probably still be life so in
the same sense that I think like you
know the table and the microphone are
examples of life and these they were
yeah yeah and so Michael Walkman and I
wrote this essay for a on about the
distinction between life and alive and
life was supposed to be like objects
like like things like microphones and
tables and chalkboards and things that
you know are require an evolutionary
process to create them but things that
are alive might be qualitative different
because there are the things that
actually actively can construct those
kind of things and so so I think I think
making those kind of distinctions can be
quite important as far as how we think
about it um I totally forgot in my train
of thoughts well if you if you define if
we agree that some aspect of life is
using information to make it matter then
maybe if the life is just in a computer
it's not doing that yeah oh okay yeah no
and that's true but it is it is in the
sense that like electrons are moving
around the computer it's just it and
that's what I mean about it being a flat
projection of it it's like so separated
what we're looking at from the
simulation from its physical
implementation that I think it's just
it's it's masking what's at what the
actual physics is yeah okay and so
that's why I favor trying to think about
chemistry from an informational
perspective and thinking about chemistry
is a substrate of information because I
can think about the physics of life at
any scale of biology but the thing
that's nice about chemistry is it's like
the base level of biological reality so
it's the easiest to see the physics
clearly so when I talk about you know
like biology creates are you biology
uses information to construct things
that couldn't exist otherwise without in
the absence of
information when I talk about that with
a molecule it's very clear like how to
think about that you know like there's
there's a certain capacities and yeah
yeah and the fact that molecular space
is huge and I but I can actually like
count that space right like the space of
possible tables I don't even know what
the objects are right so so I think I
think chemistry is a good microcosm for
studying physics of life from that
perspective and so when I study
biochemistry like we do a lot of work in
my group studying statistical
regularities and biochemistry like
trying to understand biochemistry is
like from a statistical perspective what
is what distinguishes the ensemble of
living chemistry's from nonliving
chemistry's and the way I think about
that is like part of like although I'm
just looking at chemistry the chemistry
that biology has is shaped by all of
those higher scales right so so so it's
actually still it's the physics at the
base level but it has the imprint of all
the information of the higher scales and
one way to think about that is just to
think about what is the chemical space
that technology has opened up for
example and in order to get to
technological chemical space like
pharmaceutical drugs and the kind of
things that we're doing in chemical
space now is an industrial civilization
you had to go through billions of years
of evolutionary process and chemistry
and then you know to get there so so
there is this kind of interesting thing
where life emerges from chemistry but
like if you want to talk about like
quantum physics and stuff it takes you
know billions of years for life to
invent quantum mechanics and then life
can actually impact the quantum scale by
building quantum experiments and things
so it's not like life can potentially
manipulate any scale of physical reality
but emerges in chemistry and I think
trying to understand where that imprint
is on chemistry and how many orders of
you know hierarchy like multicellularity
technology social systems and like what
their capacity is of that all that
information to then expand the space
even further and it's all interesting
different ways to use the information
right yeah that is sort of unifying
thread yeah it's a unifying thread
through like everything I think and do
but I think it's but the problem is that
question is so hard to get at you have
to look at like where can you actually
make the traction on it and so that's
one place where I feel like there's
really concrete ways of trying to get at
that physics and at least see parts of
that physics so maybe to bring it home
we can
think a little bit more pragmatically
about EXO bye all right
for one thing do you think there's life
out there
elsewhere in the universe I mean it's
kind of your job to yeah so yeah yeah no
it would it would be very weird so I
think I'm obviously like I'm a very
optimistic person in general just my
personality so I'm very hopeful there's
life out there I think that we don't
know enough about what life is though so
um and so I can't make a concrete
statement when we're the other and I
think one of the things you know
astrobiologists have a tendency to like
want to state the odds of life so you'll
often see like headlines you know like
more exoplanets are discovered the
likelihood of life in the universe has
increased you know and you're like we
have a 10% chance that any of these
exoplanets has life on it but actually
we don't have a clue right and I think
and I think just being very brutally
honest about that is actually more
constructive because you frame the way
you do the science differently
yeah then if you assume a probability
and so I try to I'm obviously I hope
life is out there but I I don't have any
assumptions about what it is or what it
looks like I just want to discover that
physics and so one way I think about the
search for life on other planets that
maybes a little bit different than other
peoples I actually really want to use
the search for life - at least bound the
probability of life and so I think that
the planets we don't find life on or
equally informative to the ones that we
might find it writes because we're at
least again it goes back to bounding the
probable result yeah so and so I
actually Morley experiment yeah exactly
so so again the history of physics
teaches us yes so biased it's so funny
it's a safe space well I think as long
as a so it like the way I use it is like
there's a narrative about how science
progressed and I think some aspects of
that narrative are really powerful for
like thinking about how science is going
to progress in the future and I think
talking about the history of physics
because physics has been really
successful in telling us about a lot of
reality like trying to learn from that
history to project like how we should
think about other problems that physics
hasn't really made traction Tania is
really useful so so I am obviously
biased as a physicist - like those
things but I also think it's a useful
lens for thinking about where we are in
the context of the history of science
do you have a favorite resolution for AI
we have not yet found life out there in
the universe yes I think I think we just
do not know what we're looking for okay
I really do and I think I think it's
really interesting you think it could be
out there all over the place
potentially yeah so so one example
because I think a lot about life is a
planetary scale phenomena so so I think
life is deeply coupled to planets and
like Earth's evolution has been
completely dependent as a planet on life
and you can't really do a couple the
history actually people have that model
exoplanets have a really hard time
modeling earth without life because we
just don't know what it would look like
and so and part of that is that biology
has controlled a lot of geochemical
cycles obviously the oxygen in our
atmosphere was controlled by biology and
so also should things about this planet
including modern climate change or
dictated by biology we're bracketed by
Venus and Mars
completely different from yeah
completely different it's a warning
right and so yes exactly
but so like yet and then you get like um
Titan which is a moon of Saturn that we
actually have a mission now dragonfly
that NASA is gonna send to tighten but
Titan could be alive but as a moon maybe
maybe it doesn't have so like it maybe
never if you think about life is a
planetary scale process or some kind of
chemical organization and something
happening that's kind of like almost
life but maybe doesn't make the
transition to sell your life and the
kind of open evolution we have then you
know maybe Titan could be alive I'm
totally a wildly speculative is not an
example but but I think that those are
the kind of things that we haven't
looked for or open yeah yeah yeah so I
think I think there's lots of lots of
potential that that life could be like
how you very specifically say it could
be alive not could Harbor life yes yes
yes yeah and yes and there but let me
just get your professional opinions on
some of the other options right just an
option that says that single-cell life
is easy and multiple cell life is hard
right an option that says once you
become intelligent you kill yourself off
right there's an option that says even
multicellular life doesn't usually
become technological because it's
underwater or something like that your
feelings about anything um I think I
think it is the case that life appears
to have gone through several bottlenecks
that are very
rare and unlikely events because they
happened once in the history of our
planet but I think that's also a matter
of scale again so so it's interesting
because when when so so they may be rare
they may be common we can't really
reason effectively about that but like
one of the ways that I like to think
about it that I think challenges some of
the ways that we even have that
discussion is to think we've had one
biosphere that's been evolving for four
billion years and it's had certain
things happen in its evolution but the
biosphere as a whole is a is a system
and we don't really think about that as
an evolving system because it's not a
Darwinian system but it is an evolving
system is changing yeah and and in some
sense the biosphere could reproduce
itself but in order to reproduce it
would have to emerge a technological
civilization that moved off planet and
terraformed another planet to look
exactly like our planet and then you
could think about planets as a whole
reproducing themselves yeah which is
kind of a crazy idea but it is the way a
planet could reproduce right so so I
think a lot of the way that we we frame
those kind of arguments and discussion
are based on certain assumptions we have
about what life is and what scale it
operates and I think we just don't know
enough about those things so so what I
try to do is just find where are the
challenges to that framework and then
how can we play with it but I don't have
a concrete answer about how I think
about it because like people make the
argument like you carry Genesis for
example happened once in the history of
our planet and that led to complex life
that's good so yeah as in the south yeah
a nucleus in a cell so we have three
domains of life archaea bacteria and
eukaryotes and the standard model so to
speak of the origin the eukaryotic cell
is that an archaea and a bacteria merged
in form eukaryotic cell and as far as we
know that happened once and so so that
event is perceived to be very rare but
multicellularity actually emerged
multiple times independently and so
people make the argument that could be
more common but it could be that these
things are predisposed based on the
biological architectures that we had
before so you had a completely different
origin of life with a different
completely different chemical bio you
know biological structure it might have
very different transitions yeah and so I
think I think we're not at the stage
where we can really reason about that
effectively do any of these
considerations have practical
implications for how we search for life
elsewhere
I think they do so so one of the things
that I've been doing a lot in the last
few years is work is starting to work
more in exoplanet science but thinking
more about how can we frame the problem
of life detection and in sort of a
statistical framework and so I've been
really advocating for more like using
statistical methods and like Bayesian
inference to try to infer the presence
of life and try to construct you know
probability distributions for what we
our expectations are and actually do it
more as an inference problem and I think
that's a more fruitful way of doing it
than saying oh we found oxygen and
methane we have a disequilibrium it's
it's alive but and so I think so the
communities starting to actually try to
build structures to try to like try to
combine multiple lines of evidence and
try to develop statistical frameworks
for life detection and I think that's a
really important Avenue of future
progress and one of the things that I've
been doing personally with my group is
working on like network theory of
planetary atmospheres so we do network
theory to characterize statistical
properties of biochemistry but you can
also do the same thing for planetary
chemistry or atmospheric chemistry and
we have like sort of a running
hypothesis that atmospheric chemistry
will have different patterns and the
molecules and the reactions used then
nonliving planets will and that we might
be able to get some insights about life
detection from that perspective we're in
the big data era yeah exactly that's
right yeah so and what I'm hoping is
that that more of the way that bio
signatures for exoplanets or even bio
signatures in the solar system are
constructed and thought about is more
moving toward Big Data approaches and
trying to use statistical tools to infer
that life is present or not all right
well if we find it you promised to come
back on the podcast I will indeed do
that for about an hour to have yes good
all right Sarah mari mari walker thanks
so much for be on the phone thanks that
was great
[Music]
you
[Music]